did you get all your tattoos when you're
in there not all of them okay I probably
have like because you're like second
you're completely covered I probably had
like seven or eight yeah when I went in
but there's not a lot to do I played I
played poker all the time I read I
worked out and yeah I got tattoos okay
I just kind of kept it myself at what
point did you start like getting close
to Luke um it was a couple years then
probably right it was a couple years in
and what made you guys talking to him
what made you want to yeah [ __ ] now
that he's gone I miss him what you want
you can't have is that what it was yeah
right well it's your brother I need to
prepare for for this yeah you guys want
to shotgun a beer shotgun is it that
time let's do it oh [ __ ] it's a good
segue mm-hmm and and then we'll have
this well to touch on the shotgun legend
that you are as well okay I heard that I
heard a I heard that you don't even
spill a drop [ __ ] I just cracked it
you're breaking the third her she's like
holy [ __ ] he's like get me the [ __ ]
Jake is the shotgun master first time
boy's mother trip Pokemon just poked
fair enough cuz you got the nice
triangle you got it all fits
I'm doing as much as you got the angle
daddy's got his upside down yeah great
have you seen those videos were they
Dave you're like so save me and Shane or
do it
Oh and then blow it at you and blow the
whole beer in your face you want to do
it
Cheers well you're only had the macho
macho man nasty savage force is gonna be
pissed
he gets mad at me he's like I don't even
smoke cigarettes in here he's a guy that
one's Oh building the rest of the
building in God yeah
Jewish with sideburns red hair no black
hair a public you ain't doing [ __ ]
please no copyright strike me oh yeah
where did we leave we're about to talk
about how me and you started talking oh
yeah how'd you guys well he would come
up he would come up to see me boy I
don't know that even before that uh how
long does it go by till your to first
visit I went in Salman County and
they're like we try to hang out like
in-between and you know like you can't
you can't be around people that are like
wrapped up and stuff like that and yeah
you try spend holidays together he comes
up he's [ __ ] up he doesn't know what
he's doing it's like you know you just
have to understand that and give him a
space and then I don't know I remember
exactly where I was when my mom calls me
like just like when you see a train
coming down the tracks you don't go stay
in the fro into the middle of traffic
and trying to stop every car that's
going by you it's it's useless you're
just gonna destroy yourself so you just
gotta accept the things that are gonna
go past you and it's like hopefully
we'll meet up again one day and you know
time goes by and I I'm living my life
and I remember when my mom called me and
there was a time in my life where every
time my mom called me I expected her to
tell me that your brother's dead yeah
and it was like a solid like four years
any time I get a call from her whether
it was good or bad I was expected the
first words out of him out to be like
Jake's dead yeah but I can't die so you
can't he's a [ __ ] cockroach I should
have been dead like a million times and
and and I had accepted that it's like I
just accepted the fact like I had I had
a brother growing up but I never had a
brother growing up and it was just
somebody that was sharing this
experience of me living in the same
space coming from the same space but we
never really like had a connection
because we were always just so different
and when he went to I was gonna make
jail or prison prison when like you go
away and like where you were at it for
like a couple years it's prison yeah so
any what's our prison like some time it
passed and I think I just like asked for
your address or whatever I just like
started writing you letters yeah no it's
awesome because uh
cuz it's like even [ __ ] up but like
people used to hang out with like you
didn't do nothing wrong to them well
they see how [ __ ] up you are so
everybody starts back in a way they cut
you off yeah yeah that everybody starts
backing away and then that's when you
start like falling back toward all these
other month like you're doing the same
[ __ ] like it's like the [ __ ] junkie
scene or something you know what I mean
just kind of you fall back into that
ground because nobody gives a [ __ ] what
you do they don't care if you're dead or
alive right you know what I mean so and
all that [ __ ] falls away and like and I
kind of saw the opportunity to have the
brother that I always wanted and I
remember very vividly I uh I got this
Simpsons anatomy book that teaches you
how to draw every character from The
Simpsons and I remember drawing this
like picture of Homer and then just like
writing the note in it about like hey
remember would like we used to like
watch The Simpsons and like eat checkers
and they'd hang out and like I think
I've really miss you I would make him
actually eat checker pieces not shove
them up my ass and like laugh about it
yeah Buford's just ride the big I'm like
that little rug the checkers
[Applause]
[Laughter]
our relationship like you're drawing
Homer Simpson you draw on home reception
no that's like anytime I like try to
like talk he just is an idiot just like
virals and we're just like two turds in
a toilet sharing this experience getting
flush down the drain the same fate wait
dissolve but you know I'm glad to be
sharing the same toilet with everybody
sitting in this table and the person
working the camera who didn't want to
shotgun a beer have to call anybody out
no but it's awesome because that's what
I was saying like you kind of lose touch
with people you hung out with in like
real friends yeah they back off and it's
not because they don't like you it's
just cuz you're [ __ ] out of control
and like me I'm like I'm mad like why is
everybody backing off and then all my
mom's gonna go [ __ ] harder [ __ ] these
[ __ ] [ __ ] nerds so I mean
that's just basically how it was so I
mean like you're sitting in there and
like you don't hear from nobody and then
you're like you're sober too and you're
like but you don't you don't like really
get it you know what I mean yeah like
what was that would explain what it was
like after it had been X amount of times
when you when you got arrested it's been
all the time in County then you finally
got transferred to prison yeah at that
point what was your like what were you
thinking about like the drug addiction
and the pills like was that how far
behind you was that that oh it wasn't
that far behind me like I was still like
you just kind of blame everything else
but like that what really happened you
know what I mean you're just grasping
onto [ __ ] to blame it on okay kinda and
that's that's kind of what I was talking
about like after like three years like I
remember talking to my mom and she was
like you're totally she came to visit me
and she's like you're totally different
like she could tell after a couple years
after like three years yeah yeah cuz
that it's kind of cliche to say but like
a fog lifted off my brain to where yeah
I thought like I'm like okay cuz that's
like I'm not I'm not stupid I just did a
lot of stupid [ __ ] yeah
so but I mean that was school hearing
her say that and just kind of
reconnected with my brother you know I
mean cuz I was a huge [ __ ] dick yeah
yeah so I mean and then it's like you
feel bad you feel bad like [ __ ] you've
done to people that care about you yeah
that you'd always push away and then you
know what I mean just just kind of [ __ ]
like that so you you deal with a lot it
was harder mentally than anything
[Laughter]